the best business model that the porn
industry ever came up with was free porn
which actually puts a dent in the
argument about AI porn putting a D in
the kind of pay for business because
what free porn did was it normalized the
use of porn for those that were not
thinking of them themselves at that time
as porn consumers and that included
children so 11-year-old boys or it
included men who do have quite healthy
real life sex lives but who thought well
I'll give it a bit of a word and then of
course and I don't buy the addiction
model I do think that it gets compulsive
and I know the way that the business
model pushes more and more extreme your
algorithms are very carefully monitored
and then you're given something a bit
more risque or a bit more close to
illegality and then of course the credit
cards can come out I think that that
that's a problem with the arguments
about AI because what AI will do is
exactly what legal brothel for example
do for the illegal industry it acts as a
smoke screen and it acts as a gateway